uh
why are you here
to fight
to win
to be a spartan
what is a spartan
a spartan is a symbol
where there is none
in times of darkness
we are hopeful
and together
together we are unstoppable
candidates are you
ready ma'am i can't hear you
again
good
who's first
to tell us more i'm excited to welcome
joseph staton the head of creative for
halo infinite hi joseph how you doing
jeff how you been it's great to be with
you in person yes thank you so much for
coming down all the way from seattle
yeah you guys are working very hard on
the game but you made the trek to
opening night live and it means a lot to
us uh what did we just see there so that
was the introduction to halo infinite
multiplayer's first free-to-play season
where you'll meet commander agrinia the
leader of a whole new generation of
spartans and agreement is a key
character as you begin your own personal
spartan journey that will continue from
season to season
well it looks uh looks great uh speaking
of multiplayer uh the the tests were you
know i was playing a couple weeks ago
tons of fun i know did you play yes and
the team had i think a lot of great
feedback from the fans it's real uh and
i think everyone wants to know how is
development going on the game yeah well
like you said we started flighting our
multiplayer earlier this month and i
gotta say it was great to see the
positive reaction and all the energy
that came out of the test
and i just want to thank everybody for
jumping in and playing at the same time
we're putting the finishing touches on
our most wide open and adventure filled
halo campaign ever
and today
i would like to announce that halo
infinite's campaign and multiplayer will
launch together on december 8th
this year december 8th it's real this
holiday just as you promised well i know
you and the team have been working so
hard uh to land this and exciting that
you know campaign and multiplayer will
both be coming this year because it's
it's kind of an important year it's the
20th anniversary of xbox and halo right
that's right it's a big year and um for
this 20th anniversary we might have
something a little special up our
sleeves oh okay well uh shall we take a
look why don't we let's do it
[Music]
get ready
[Music]
that's some controller
yeah definitely now jeff yes it wouldn't
be an anniversary celebration if we
didn't do
one more thing oh there's more just one
okay uh here's the last thing i think
all right joe thank you very much let's
take a look at this
this is
spartan117
can anyone hear me over
we need to fight
get ready
[Music]
okay next